طائرة هليكوبتر روسية تحلق فوق
خط الشجرة مباشرة ، وقد انطلقت من السماء
بما يقول المحللون إنه من المحتمل أن يكون
صاروخًا مضادًا للطائرات إذا كنت
طيارًا روسيًا لطائرة هليكوبتر ، فأنت لا تعرف أبدًا
أين سيأتي هذا من
هذا الفيديو المنشور بواسطة  الجيش الأوكراني
cnn غير قادر على التحقق من وقت
حدوث ذلك ، صاروخ Stinger مضاد للطائرات يسعى للحرارة بمدى
خمسة أميال و 11 ألف
قدم سلاح ذكي لدرجة أنه يمكن أن يميز
طائرة معادية ويبدأ في نعيق
صديق أو عدو كما يبدو  بالنسبة للأهداف التي
من المفترض أن تصيبها ،
لذا إذا أطلقت لاذعًا على طائرة أمريكية من طراز f-15 ،
فمن المحتمل أن تكون قد أخطأت ، ولكن عندما تضع
طائرة روسية الصنع في الهواء
وتستخدم
لسعًا أمريكيًا ، فسيخبر المسؤولون الأمريكيون ذلك
لقد أرسلت الولايات المتحدة وحلف الناتو إلى الأوكرانيين
آلاف الأسلحة اللاذعة مثل ستينجر
وقد تم استخدامها بشكل فعال وأعتقد
أن الأوكرانيين سيستمرون
في استخدام تلك الأسلحة في تكتيكات الوحدات الصغيرة مع
بتأثير كبير والغرب قد أرسل
الرماح وهو نظام صاروخي موجه مضاد للدبابات
يطلق على الكتف بمدى
يزيد عن 8 آلاف قدم وهو يطلق
سلاحًا يرتفع في الهواء ثم
ينزل ويصيب بالفعل دبابة أو
مركبة من فوق  يفعل ذلك لأنه يحتوي
على دروع أقل في الأعلى بشكل عام
أكثر عرضة للخطر ،
وقد وضع الجيش الأوكراني العديد من مقاطع الفيديو التي
تظهر براعته الفتاكة في استخدام
هذه الأسلحة الغربية الصنع ضد
الروس.
يتعرض عمود الدبابة الروسية
للهجوم بصواريخ الرمح واللمعان الحاسمة بالنسبة للأوكرانيين ،
ويقول المحللون جزئيًا إن
ما يسمى بنيرانهم ونسيان
نيران الأسلحة ونسيانها حتى تتمكن من إطلاقها ومن
ثم يمكن للشخص الذي يطلقها أن
يجرف الروس ويقول الخبراء أن لديهم أسلحة خاصة بهم
أسلحة فعالة جدًا في أوكرانيا من
طراز إسكندر وصواريخ عيار
ودبابات T-72 خفيفة الوزن ولكنهم
متهمون أيضًا باستخدام قنابل عنقودية و
الاستعداد لاستخدام ما يسمى
بالقنابل الفراغية أو الحرارية التي لا
يُفترض استخدامها في المناطق المدنية.
يتم دعم
صواريخهم التي تطلق من على الكتف من
خلال تكتيكات روسية قذرة في بعض الأحيان ،
فهم يصطفون دباباتهم وناقلات
الجند المدرعة
التي تعرفها من الأنف إلى الأنف إلى فاني
تسير في الشارع ولا يوجد
أمن للجناح الأمني على اليسار أو ال
مين وهكذا هم  تصبح بطة جالسة
فعالة مثل هذه الأسلحة ،
يُقال إن المسؤولين الأمريكيين لم
يعطوا الأوكرانيين أحدث إصدارات
الأسلحة مثل صواريخ ستينغر خوفًا من
أن يقع بعضها في ساحة المعركة بطريقة ما
في أيدي
الروس الذين قد يقعون في أيدي الروس.
سرقة ذئب التكنولوجيا
[موسيقى]